[MUSIC PLAYING]
For modern mobile applications,
rendering performance
can often be the most common
thief of your precious frame
time.
These issues are easy to
create, easy to fall into,
and, with the help
of a handy tool,
they're easy to
track down as well.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And with the Profile
GPU Rendering tool,
you've got a handy,
on-device ability
to see exactly what's causing
slowdowns in your application.
To get access to this tool,
simply go into Developer Mode
and select the Profile
GPU Rendering option.
This will prompt you
for a secondary screen
on how you'd like to
collect your profiling data.
For ease of use, select the
On Screen As Bars option.
Doing so will reward you with
a plethora of colors and bars
on your device.
You'll notice that for
each visible activity,
this tool is
displaying a profiling
graph drawn on top of it.
For example, the
graph at the bottom
represents rendering performance
coming from the navigation
activity there.
The upper graph represents time
gone to the notification bar.
And the graph in the middle
contains all the performance
information from the
active application.
Since that's the one we're
actually interested in,
let's focus our attention there.
As you interact with
your application,
you'll see that the
vertical bars show up
on your screen appearing
from left to right.
Each vertical bar represents
one frame of rendering.
The taller the bar, the
longer it took to render.
And as you render
more frames, they'll
be stacked next to
each other so you
can see the influence
of frame rate over time.
That green line there actually
represents 16 milliseconds,
and it moves around based
on the overall scale
of the bars themselves.
To hit 60 frames
a second, you need
to make sure that each one of
these frames' vertical bars
stays under that 16
millisecond mark.
Anytime you see a bar
push above that mark,
you're going to see some
pauses in your animations.
Now the astute
observer will notice
that each bar is
actually comprised
of three colors stacked
on top of each other.
These colors directly relate
to a portion of the Android
rendering pipeline
and how long it
took to actually run that frame.
The blue section of that
bar represents draw time
or, rather, how long it took to
create and update your display
lists in Java.
Remember that before a view
can actually be rendered,
it has to first be transformed
into a GPU-friendly format.
On the simple side of
this, it could just
be a few Draw commands.
But on the complex end, we could
be tessellating a custom path
coming from your canvas object.
Once done, the results
are then cached
as a display list
object by the system.
This blue bar is
recording how much time
it takes to complete these
two steps for all the views
that need to be updated
on the screen this frame.
When you see this
bar shoot high,
it could mean that
a bunch of views
suddenly became
invalidated, or it
may be a few custom
views who might
have some extremely
complex logic
in their On-Draw function.
Now the red section of the
bar represents execute time.
This is the time spent
by Android's 2D renderer
to Execute Display List.
See, in order to
draw to the screen,
Android needs to draw your
display list information
by interfacing with the OpenGL
ES API, which effectively
passes along data to the GPU,
which then, ultimately, ends up
putting pixels on the screen.
Remember that for more complex
views, like a custom view,
the more complex the commands
needed for OpenGL to draw it.
And when you see this
red bar shoot high,
these complex views
are a likely culprit.
It's also worth noting that
large spikes in this bar
can come from re-submitting
a load of views
to be redrawn again.
These views haven't
necessarily been invalidated.
But if something happens,
like a view rotates,
then we need to go
back and clean up
areas of the screen
that might be affected
by that by redrawing
the views underneath it.
And finally, the orange
section of the bar
represents the process time.
Or rather, this is where
the CPU tells the GPU
that it's done
rendering a frame.
This action is a blocking
call, and as such, the CPU
will sit around and
wait for the GPU
to acknowledge that it's
received the command.
If this bar is
getting large, then it
means that you're doing
a lot of work on the GPU,
resulting from many
complex views that
require a lot of OpenGL
rendering commands
to be processed.
The key to getting silky smooth
animations that respond to user
input is keeping all of these
vertical bars below that 16
millisecond line as
often as possible.
Any time the column
spikes up above that,
you're going to end
up missing a frame,
and the users won't enjoy that.
Using Profile GPU
Rendering is a nifty tool
that can give you immediate
insight into where
you may be having problems
in your rendering pipeline.
But fixing those problems
is easier said than done.
So check out the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns
content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ Community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]